sorry famine yes my first love broke my
heart for the first time and I was like
baby baby baby oh I'm like baby baby hi
Justin I'm Justine just nice to meet you
nice to meet you
so I'm making a little youtube video you
know I know you know you make youtube
videos yes so what would you say to
aspiring musicians on YouTube making
videos no and please all get to that I
would tell them so basically I don't
know YouTube is a great place to you
know put put videos to get yourself out
there so that's you know one way but
another way you know just always follow
your dream is show you before God first
so with your favorite song to play live
my favorite song to play live right now
is probably baby baby I think the
dancing a lot better than me so on one
last thing do someone say hi to
everybody on YouTube here Cole what's up
everybody thank you for all the support
on my - my new album I want to point out
I down
thank you so much all right so guys
justin is inside an autograph and one of
you guys will get it ready to make sure
they do something crazy to get this up
what you wanted to do last time make an
awesome me - Julia make an awesome
YouTube video okay so that's it make an
awesome youtube video and you can have
this wonderful automatically ver yeah
thank you so much and you are the best
you are adorable you by the way
Oh sing it everybody Oh
oh you know you love me I know you care
you shall whenever and I'll be there
you're my love you want my heart and we
will never ever ever be apart are we an
item girl quit playing witches friends
what are you saying said there's another
look right in my
eyes my first love broke my heart for
the first time and I was like baby baby
baby